Well,
I've been very,
very involved with star,
uh,
since,
since I first came because the mission
there was to transform it from a tabloid
into a glossy magazine,
which is totally necessary because after
us came out,
it really changed the landscape of
celebrity reporting and tabloids as
we're vulnerable because as newspapers,
young people aren't for a long time,
haven't been reading newspapers and that
trend has been continuing and tablets
are really a newspaper.
So,
um,
star need to star needed to get a
younger audience and needed to go more
upscale in order to attract advertising,
which it couldn't carry is a tabloid.
And so,
uh,
American media decided that they were
going to need this transition.
It never been done before and Anna,
it's never going to be done again.
There's no other tablet that really is
convertible.
So that was a real challenge.
But I was very interested in that
challenge and I came in and we did that
and it took,
I would say it took a good four years to
really get accepted.
It's only been in the last,
this last year that I feel we've really
patched past the tipping point.
We've gained this whole new younger
audience.
We've got the advertisers to except the
magazine and advertising's up 26%.
And so it's really in the last year I've
been able even know I was,
I the other magazine I've been fairly
involved with for a while it's shape
because it really needed to also
transition.
And a couple of years ago it brought in
a new editor and you creative director
and we redesigned and and read is we re
um,
kind of not just did a physical
redesigned but kind of really reformat
it the way we were presenting the
editorial so and the text.
And so,
and that's actually worked out very,
very well.
They're having their best year ever now
too.
So,
but until this last year I really didn't
get a chance to,
to oversee and focus on any other
magazines.
And now because star has had that
tipping point,
I've been able to pull back from it and
not be so involved in the day to day.
And I've been much more involved with,
I'm working on country weekly,
which is also needed to be redesigned.
I don't have updated,
uh,
it's fun magazine,
natural health,
men's fitness,
and even getting a little bit involved
with the myth that the men's muscle
titles,
which is very brand new to me.
So,
and then I work a lot also on doing
still a lot of the marketing and
advertising
and working with publishers.